نذهب الى هذا الخبر
حسناء ضمن الفريق القانوني لرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب خطفت الانظار وتصدرت
ترند
الينا حبه المحاميه العربيه الاصل اصبحت
حديثه وسائل الاعلام خاصه بعد ظهورها
المتكرر على الشاشات للدفاع عن شم ولد في
ولايه نيويوركس لمهاجرين عراقيين والان
اصبحت تمتلك شركه مكونه من خمسه محامين
ولها مكاتب في نيوجيرسي تعود علاقتها
عندما ساعدته في رفع دعوه وعده دعوى ضد
هلال كلينتون وبقيت الى جانب ترامب على
الرغم من انه استبدل عده محامين خلال هذه
المعارك القضائيه تصفها مجله نيوزويك
بانها واحده من اكثر محاميه ترامب موثوقيه
عنده فيما ارتفعت ثروتها الشخصيه بعد
تعاملاتها مع ترامب كعميل حيث بلغ دخلها
السنوي ما يقدر ب 210,000 دولار في 2021